vamos a dividir 518 entre
0.7 y lo que quiero que aquí vean es que
vamos a tener un número entero dividido
entre un decimal como vamos a manejarlo
ahorita veremos este mismo 518 entre 0.7
lo podemos reescribir de la siguiente
forma
518 en tren
0.7
como lograremos convertir este decimal
en un número entero vamos a multiplicar
tanto el divisor como el dividendo por
10 de hecho lo que haremos es
multiplicar este 0.7 por 10 y se
recorrerá el punto decimal estaremos
haciendo 1
una multiplicación que nos envíe el
número decimal hacia la derecha y
haremos lo mismo aquí 518 realmente es
518.000 el punto decimal que tenemos
aquí al multiplicarlo por 10 se
recorrerá hacia la derecha igual que lo
hicimos con el divisor y tendremos ahora
5.180 si lo vemos en términos de
fracciones 518 entre 0.7 es igual a 518
sobre 0.7 y como lo hemos manejado en
las fracciones cuando multiplicamos
tanto el numerador como el denominador
por 10 recorreremos el punto decimal
hacia la derecha que esto será igual
5.180
entre sí
y con eso tendremos una división larga
lo que si hemos de poner mucho cuidado
es en qué lugar quedó el punto en este
caso quedó aquí 5.180 vamos a subir el
punto decimal para que tengamos cuidado
de su lugar vamos a limpiar esto un poco
y con eso quedará mucho más claro dónde
ha quedado el punto decimal al haber
multiplicado punto 7 por 10 lo que
hicimos fue dejar nuestro divisor como
7.00 y al multiplicar nuestro dividendo
por 10 de 518 hemos quedado en 5 mil 180
donde el punto quedará en esta posición
vamos a borrar todo y nos quedamos con
el punto perfectamente marcado ahora
vamos a hacer esta división como una
división larga común tenemos que cuántas
veces nos cabe 7 dentro del 5 realmente
no nos cabe ninguna podemos colocar el 0
o directamente me voy con 51 vámonos por
este camino 51 es más grande que 7 y 7
cabe siete veces en 50 y 17 por 7 es
igual a 49 si a 51 le restó 49 tendré 2
y de la misma manera que hemos manejado
las divisiones largas bajaremos este
siguiente número que será el 8
28 cuantas veces cada vez 7 en 28 cabe 4
4 x 7 es igual a 28 sea 28 el resto 28
tengo 0 en este caso es importantísimo
que bajemos al menos hasta donde
llegamos con los decimales el punto
decimal se encuentra aquí por lo que
este sea aún no bajaremos para tener
nuestra respuesta adecuada
y también si se fijan estoy teniendo
mucho cuidado en colocar el número en el
cociente de tal manera que quede
exactamente bajo el número del dividendo
que hemos que hemos tomado al dividir 51
entre 7 colocó el 7 en este 1 al dividir
28 entre 7 el 4 quedó exactamente encima
del 8 y en este caso que tendremos ceros
pondré que el 0 dividido entre 7 será 0
justo a la altura de las unidades que es
exactamente el mismo cero que hemos
bajado y 0 por 7 es igual a 0
0 - 0 nos da residuo de 0 con lo que
tenemos que
518 entre 0.7 será igual